on our back to the Labour conference in
the victory of Jeremy Gorman he lost the
confidence of 172 million physicals with
over 60 shadow ministers resigning
during the summer but Jeremy Corbyn not
only clung on but strengthened his
mandate Urkel's in the leadership
contest that's just being concluded so
is it out of time for the rebels to row
in behind him dynamic is the shadow
health secretary and remained loyal of
course to the leader through that a very
good morning to you Diane sir how do you
interpret this result in terms of what
it means for those 172 mps you so they
had no confidence in you know one of the
things which hurts own Smith his canvas
is found is people didn't like the coup
people thought Jeremy hadn't been given
a chance and I think that the people
that signed emotion their confidence we
need to listen to that and make the
members aware that they're willing to
give Jamie a chance by actually
supporting it well seem a Malhotra's
just been there in that chair she of
course resigned from the Shadow Cabinet
and she said and she's willing to to
consider getting in behind Jeremy gone
but things have to change in terms of
threateningly selection some Shadow
Cabinet elections and no more of this
online abuse
well the online abuse is not directed or
sanctioned by anybody in the leadership
and Jeremy's condemned it from the
beginning in terms of shadow carbon
elections I'm not against um a principle
with a lot of discussions to be had
about the ones Democratic Democratic
context however it seems that people
will come back anyway because that's
what the party wants the party wants the
party in Westminster to unite and fight
the toilets so it's kind of taking a
horse to water but you can't force them
to drink we know they don't want Jeremy
but you're saying they must now listen
to the membership and hold their noses
and serve under general
particularly on the domestic agenda
there's a lot of agreement in the
parliamentary Labour Party around health
around education about holding you know
tis about coming into Parliament and
doing the job but are you in a way as a
loyal supporter of Jeremy Corbyn and
friend Andy a unit way pleased that Owen
Smith launched this campaign it
it's entrenched Jeremy called and hasn't
it's strengthened it it's May Jeremy
stronger but of course we could have
with in so many more things as summer
rather than being ordinary leadership
campaign we should have been attacking
the Tories even more so I'm glad it's
over
and I hope that people listen to the
party the party should could not be
clearer the party is saying we want you
all to unite behind the leader what
happens if that doesn't have one ounce
if there is still muttering not even at
the margins but in the centre of the
parliamentary Labour Party I don't
believe love anybody serious it's going
to continue this into nice animal so you
always have mutters in Parliament
whichever party you're talking about but
I believe people now are ready to unite
the most important thing but it's this
issues you say if Jeremy Corbyn being
strengthened by all this was all said
about Stalin wasn't it that he had
written the names of his enemies on the
bullets that he was gonna shoot them
with but Jeremy Corbyn said he's going
to go the other way Olive Branch it so
is it bullets or Oliver it's olive
branches all the way Jamie's not that
type of person
Jeremy is prepared to forget the things
that were said during the campaign he
wants to bring people together and you
have to remember it's that that
leadership campaign and the
unpleasantness that helped to solidify
Jeremy's support so what form does the
Olive Branch take what's he going to do
well I think that Reggie says that
everything's been done perfectly
in the last year I entirely resist this
notion that jeremy has been you know
masterminding online abuse but you know
I think we have to learn from our
mistakes as a leadership team and go on
it's about pressing the reset button
well tell me more what pressing the
reset button means does it be the root
and branch look again at the policies
many of the MPs disagree with so many
things things like that the nuclear
policy and others and also the style of
the leadership coterie around Joe I
would stress that on domestic policy
there's already a great deal of unity
and many of the most contentious issues
for our politicians like the bombing of
Syria and our for better or worse behind
us in terms of the way the leaders
office operates his Commissioner Gaur
called Bob Paisley who was a Topsail
servant to look at the structure of the
office to make it more efficient we have
learned from the stars here we want to
have a office which increases operation
is more responsive we you know we were
willing to listen to constructive
criticism what do you think about that
disconnect you describe it yourself you
know with many of the activists and
constituency members voting for Jeremy
and their auntie's not supporting it
doesn't that inevitably lead to more
discussion about being selection no no
really most active a similar rifle
bearing many of Jeremy strongest critics
actually the party nominated Jeremy I
think you know parties you know that
this talk about Rhys election it's
really coming from Jeremy's image it's
not gonna come Jamie at all
there will be selections because of the
bands which yes you'll have to
understand that what I was listening to
Jeremy Corbyn on the marsh show this
morning and he didn't actually rule it
out altogether he said things like that
well why didn't he just save let's put
out this olive branch why doesn't he
just say that we'll open baby
that you know it's up to your
constituents buddy come to time for
general election and you'll be fine
that's the position where a Democratic
Party constituency parties choose a
representative we are not intervening
from the center there is no question of
mandatory selection there's not going to
be a purge we just want to put some of
the very unpleasant things that was said
oh by Jamie's opponents behind us and we
want to wash our pleasure
oh that he was somehow closet and to
seem like that he summer had a problem
with women do you know there was issues
throughout the leadership campaign about
Jamie and women and yet 67% of Labor
women voted to Jamie so they knew that
was all not a but I mean there is that
issue seeing as you raise it at that
Labor Party and being that led by women
look at a vast number of parties in the
UK both nationally and in some of the
other nations of the UK led by women
isn't it talk that lucky [ __ ] should
well you know me only a good time I
think we have a woman needing but for
now for now no no no but for now
Jeremy's the leader i Jamie's gonna lead
us into 20 pence okay tell me we're
going to talk about your brief because
of course big developments there and
with the health service and the BMA
calling off all the strikes they pulled
off one and then we're still in the
balance as to whether the others would
go ahead do you think that's the right
decision I think if they're concerned
about patient safety it is obviously the
right decision but they still have an
incredibly strong case and Joni hunt
brought all these problems on himself by
his decision to impose the contract you
wouldn't want a contract imposed on you
so why should the junior doctors have a
contract imposed on them but this was an
opportunity wasn't as you described on I
think the most important issue for the
British public for for labor to give a
clear message as to what you thought
about that period when as they say the
BMA the junior doctors record off one of
the five days strikes and is still in
consideration as to whether the others
would go ahead and you didn't stand up
and say well do or don't do it you've
now gone no it's not now going to hit
okay I'll support you whatever it is
what are you not saying because they not
think it's wrong it's not for political
parties to tell trade unions
to conduct their dispute well we've been
very clear about is we support the
junior doctors cause when they said this
government can scarcely fund a five day
a week NHS how is it going to fund a
seven-day week NHS I've just come from a
major local hospital they're all in
there working on a Sunday and yet Jeremy
Hunt was trying to claim the problem was
doctors weren't willing to well there
are more patients than doctors here may
have finally come to the assessment so
that it might have damaged patients
initially they said they wouldn't why
didn't you say at the time this will
damage patients don't do it find another
way the doctors themselves can make that
assessment and they made that assessment
because as you know for doctors patient
safety is the most important